Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I was really looking forward to this paper. This
says that GPT-4, an AI has perhaps a spark of
intelligence. That is a huge claim, and when we
looked into this paper earlier, we saw that it
can do incredible things. It finds its way around
in an imaginary maze, and even make a map for it.
And it also learned to see. Now why would that
be so important, there are tons of learning-based
techniques out there that understand images
and even video. So why is this so crazy? Well,
it is not only crazy, but we thought it was flat
out impossible! Why? Well, because this AI never
saw an image, just text and textual descriptions
of things, yet it can draw these. Outstanding.
And its mathematical skills are nearly on the
level of the International Mathematical Olympiad.
And today I can’t wait, because
we are going to have a deeper
look together at what else it can
do, and things that it can’t. Yes,
we will see good and bad and I
think you will be very surprised.
First, when we ask how many prime numbers
are there between 150 and 250, it says 13.
Without commenting on this, let’s rephrase the
question. Now, little AI, list the prime numbers
between 150 and 250, then count them up.
Then, it starts listing, and…uh-oh.
18. So, which one is it, 13 or 18?
Well, the correct answer is indeed
18. This is insanity! The AI clearly has
the knowledge to solve this problem, yet,
depending on how we ask, it either knows or it
doesn’t. So how is this even possible? Well,
the problem is that the first prompt is not
computerly enough. Let me explain - you see,
the second prompt allows it to think in a step
by step manner, which has been shown to lead to
better results. Sometimes. And that is a huge
point. Why is that? Well, because of something
that happened 73 years ago. Now I hear you asking,
what do you mean Károly? What is this insanity?
Well, Isaac Asimov, famous science-fiction
writer created an imaginary world with
intelligent robots, that sometimes showed
unexpected behavior. In these cases,
robopsychologists were called to find
out what is going on in the brain of
this little AI. And he wrote this about 73
years ago. And today, here we are. The first
robopsychologists are appearing in our real world.
How incredible is that? What a time to be alive!
Now, next one. Storytelling. Here,
the first letters are already given,
it has to fill them so that it forms a story about
unicorns. And, we also ask that the story has a
twist to it. So, can it do it? Yes, it will do
it perfectly. No robopsychology is required here.
But then, when we show it one of the
simplest math problem you can imagine,
and ask for the result of another one, it
fails. What in the world is happening? This
AI can read and evaluate electrocardiograms as
well as some of the smartest humans out there,
but it often can’t solve a problem
that a child could easily solve.
So this is the age we live in. We have an
AI that can create a nice little network
graph describing the relation of movie
titles, directors and writers with real
data grabbed from IMDB, but keeps making
arithmetic errors on really simple tasks.
This is the age where an AI can write a
computer game in Javascript super quickly,
and solve classical fun thought experiments
with logic. It even uses common sense to find
out about the rules of the game by itself. And
it does it even better than its predecessor,
but it has no idea what year
it is. What is even worse,
it says different things at different
times, and all of them are wrong.
And I wonder what all of these will look like
just two more papers down the line. Now, this
video took a bit of time as I wanted the dust to
settle a bit and gather you the most interesting
experiments from this 155-page long paper. This
is not great for views, but that doesn’t matter.
What matters is that you get more information
about ChatGPT and GPT-4, which is going to be
the future of many many things. I am so happy that
we can drill down a bit deeper with this episode.
And this GPT-4 AI has been deployed in ChatGPT,
so you can try the previous version for free,
or pay for the GPT-4 enabled ChatGPT. And
that means we have an important moment here.
Why? Well, because through this assistant,
we indeed see the papers in these videos
come alive. And as it has over a 100 million
users, we can confidently say that today,
everyone is talking about the Papers! Some might
not know about it, but they do. How cool is that?
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!